ئر وجد قبل التاريخ،
وُصِفَ بأنه مثلث رعب
مسكون بالجن كمثلث برمودا،
وقيل أنه أبغض مكان على وجه الأرض
، وأنه سجن للجن،
كثرت عنه الروايات والقصص،
فهم يقولون أن من نزله لايعود،
وأن ماءه هو أسوأ ماء على وجه الأرض،
وأن الرسول قد ذمه  في أحاديثه
، ما دفع فريقاً عمانياً للنزول إلى قاع البئر
، فهل وجدوا الجن حقا؟
وماذا كان مصدر الأصوات التي فيه
، ولماذا كل ذلك الرعب
خوفا من البئر قبل نزول الفريق العماني؟
أسئلة سنجيب عليها في دقائق هذا الفيديو
بئر  في محافظة المهرة اليمنية،
ذكرت حوله العديد من الروايات
لكنها غير مؤكدة، فقالوا أن ملوك الجن
هم من حفروا البئر وجعلوه سجنا لمن يعصيهم من أتباعهم،
ولا يوجد بها غير الثعابين والخفافيش  والحيات والحمام،،
وقالوا أيضا أن امرأة كانت ترعى بجانب البئر،
وتركت طفلها بجوار البئر لكنها غفلت عنه لوهلة،
وعندما نظرت إلى طفلها فلم يعد موجودا مكانه،
وتقول رواية أخرى أن بعضا من سكان المنطقة
قرروا استكشاف المكان،
فلما وصلوا ربطوا أحدهم،
وأنزلوه إلى قاع البئر
لكنهم لم يسمعوا منه شيئا
ولماا طال انتظارهم لصاحبهم قرروا رفعه بالحبل
لكن لم يكن موجود غير الجزء العلوي من جسده فقط،
ولما كثرت الأقاويل قرر مجموعة أخرى من الناس التأكد،
فذهبوا للبئر وربطوا واحدا منهم فأنزلوه
ولما وصل إلى عمق٥٠ مترا طلب من أصدقائه رفعه،
فسألوه عن السبب قال أنه كان في مكان مظلم،
وشعر بأن البئر ستغلق عليه،
وكان مزودا بكاميرات لتصوير ما يحدث،
ولما رأوا التسجيلات، كان كل شيء مظلم على الرغم أنهم في وقت الظهيرة،،
كل الروايات السابقة كانت تقول أن البئر مظلم
ولا يستطيع أحد أن ينظر إلى قاعه إلا عند تعامد الشمس عليه،،
ويقال أن الرسول صلى الله عليه وسلم قال عنه بعض الأحاديث
ومنها قوله
<< خير ماء على وجه الأرض ماء زمزم،
فيه طعام من الطعم، وشفاء من السقم، وشر ماء على وجه الأرض
ماء برهوت بقية حضرموت كرجل الجراد من الهوام،
يصبح يتدفق، وتمسي لا بلال بها>>
كما قال فيها الإمام علي ابن أبي طالب
«أبغض البقاع إلى الله تعالى وادي برهوت بحضرموت
فيه بئر ماؤها أسود منتن يأوي إليه أرواح الكفار»،
وفي إحدى القصص التي ذكرها الأصمعي عن رجل من حضرموت
أنه قال: إنا نجد من ناحية برهوت رائحة منتنة فظيعة جداً
فيأتينا الخبر أن عظيماً من عظماء الكفّار قد مات.
ويحكى أن رجلاً بات ليلة بهذا الوادي؛ قال:
فكنت أسمع طول الليل «يا دومة يا دومة» فذكرت ذلك لبعض أهل العلم
فقال: إن الملك الموكل بأرواح الكفار اسمه دومة.
(القول الفصل)
على مدى قرون ظلت هذه الروايات والخرافات التي تقال عن البئر،
ولم يستطع أحد أن ينكرها، حتى قرر فريق عماني متخصص
بالمغامرات والاستكشاف الذهاب إلى البئر
والتأكد من كل الأقاويل التي قيلت عنه،
وصل الفريق إلى البئر وحضر هناك العديد من سكان المنطقة
في محافظة المهرة ممن أثارهم الفضول ليعرفوا حقيقة البئر،
وعندما نزل الفريق إلى عمق البئر أخذ كل مقاييسه وكل مواصفاته،
فالبئر عبارة عن حفرة كبيرة:
...عمقها (١١٢ مترا)
... وقطر فوهة الفجوة من الأعلى (٣٠مترا)
... بينما قطر القاع من الأسفل(١١٦مترا)
... ونسبة الأكسجين فيه طبيعية جدا،
.. وتبلغ درجة الحرارة فيه(٣٠درجة مئوية)
.. ومياهه نقية وعذةب جدا
.. وتوجد فيها ٤ شلالات والمياه تخرج من جدران البئر،
وتنزل إلى قاع حفرته، وتتسرب في تجويف جانبي بطول ٤ أمتار
، بدون أي زيادة في مستوى سطح الماء،
بينما وجد الفريق كتابات باللغة الإنجليزية على جدران البئر،
وهو ما يؤكد أن الإنجليز جعلوا منه مقراً لعملياتهم أثناء احتلال جنوب اليمن،
وبهذا فقد دحض الفريق العماني كل الروايات والقصص والخرافات السابقة
، وبهذه السمات الموجودة في البئر سيصبح مزارا سياحيا
يقصده الزوار من أرجاء المعمورة.
هناك رواية أخرى تقول أن الأحاديث التي نسبت للنبي والأقاويل
التي نسبت للصحابة، لم تقصد بئر برهوت الذي اكتشفه الفريق العماني
وإنما وادٍ في حضرموت ونحن فريق شاهد لتعرف
قمنا بالبحث عن صور بئر برهوت الشهير
فوجدنا أن صوره مطابقة تماما للصور التي التقطها الفريق العماني
ولذلك فنحن نرجح بأن البئر هو ذات البئر
ولكن مناطق شرق اليمن عامة كانت تسمى قديما حضرموت
ولكم أن تتأكدوا من ذلك من خلال محركات البحث،
واعتمدوا على المصادر التي ترونها موثوقة،..
.. وأنتم متابعينا هل صدقتم الروايات السابقة من قبل؟
وما هو رأيكم فيما تم ذكره في هذا الفيديو،
نرجو وضع إجاباتكم أو أي استفسارت أو أي إضافات للموضوع في التعليقات...